two well here we are again
they said we wouldn't return
they always say that they go oh he'll
never be back after every episode
he's leaving in disgrace but no i am
back
and this time with a good episode for a
change
with because with us today is andrew
callahan
the genius behind all gas no breaks
this is a young man you're going to be
hearing his name you're going to be
seeing him i'll tell
many of you already know him but the
legend of andrew callahan
is growing by the day and continues to
grow
andrew thank you for coming into the h3
podcast
thanks for having me on this is dope i'm
a big fan oh you are you are
yeah i've watched a few videos and i'm
always loying
all right we got the laws going i
appreciate that we are all
fans of your work yeah i've watched
everything i mean i've watched it all
right let me let me for people who are
unfamiliar with your work
i think i'll best summarize it by
youtube
comment that i read under one of your
videos and you tell me how accurate it
is
they said your show is like the eric
andre show
except the interviewer is normal and
everyone around him
is eric andre yeah it's i've seen that
come out before too
that's a very good one it had twenty
thousand likes so i was like wow twenty
thousand likes
yeah that's a great observation yeah
i'm like straight man versus like psycho
is that is
you feel like that's an accurate
representation of what you do do you
feel like you go out into the craziest
place you can find it just play it
straight
well sometimes like sometimes like at
the coronavirus lockdown protest or like
when i go to the flat earth convention
yeah it's definitely like that but i've
been trying to cover some more like
serious stuff like the minneapolis thing
wasn't so much like that but you know a
lot of stuff's like that
it's pretty pretty fair the minneapolis
um
actually i want to pull that up because
you know
the mini the minneapolis video to me
actually i found
like i was learning more from your video
than a lot of the coverage i found you
went in there
and you went inside what was the store
there was a rioting
the store was on fire it was smoking
people were writing and you're in there
asking people questions it was just it
was just amazing yeah i went it was uh
kmart on lake street kmart minneapolis
were you scared being in there what was
your vibe
i don't know no i wasn't scared i just
you know
just all gas no brakes exactly yeah
there it is that kind of was like a
perfect all gas no bricks moment i feel
like
yeah i mean i get more scared at like
you know frat parties and stuff like
that
[Laughter]
cause they'll turn on you i'm saying i
kinda to pull up that clip so people
because i feel like that that's a good
representation of the kind of
can we call it gonzo journalism can we
call it that you can definitely call it
that
yeah that video was really
meaningful and like i felt like
it was the best piece of journalism that
i saw during that time because we had
the news on
the whole time like you couldn't turn it
off everything was so crazy but
it's just i don't know the way they
cover stuff is so like
boots they're not boots on the ground no
and they just focus
obviously on whatever they think is
going to make a good height a
headline but i feel like this was
so real and you really got to see what
people were
about and why they were doing what they
were doing yeah well thank you i
appreciate that there's actually a scene
in the video where i found one of like
the news correspondents it's like
halfway through
i was walking away from the scene and
like up on this freeway right here
can you see what i'm
sorry we're about to go on air here so i
gotta
all right so here's this part where you
go into the you said it was a kmart and
you just start interviewing the looters
which is
something i would never think to do but
here we are and it's actually quite
enlightening let's watch this
[Music]
everything must go i think we're just
causing enough chaos to get attention
you know you want this [ __ ] going man
you're
there's like [ __ ] on fire bro and you're
just cruising through there
what did you i found like when you were
talking to them i didn't feel like
threatened
or like that people didn't seem very
violent correct me they weren't very
violent i mean aside from the property
damage
happening it wasn't like uh the violence
wasn't being exerted on each other it
wasn't like people were running out in
the streets and like beating the [ __ ]
out of each other it was just an
expression of like pain
rage in that area yeah i didn't really
feel unsafe at all during the
riots or protests there that's really i
felt i got shot by
you know by a national guardsman with
the rubber bullet it was like this big
yes when i was interviewing someone so i
mean oh my god
i got shot by the guard i was threatened
by them
but no i the reason i didn't do any
interviews inside the kmart is because
it's like super incriminating you know
interview people so i just got those
shots of me walking around and the
reason i held up that
hanukkah sweater is because everything
was
looted from inside the store except for
like a few specifics
it was like baby pants hanukkah sweaters
and like just
printers and [ __ ] they were just like
there untouched so i was just like
walking around
i actually filmed this segment called
like what didn't get looted but i never
dropped it because it was just like too
funny
and like oh my god the situation but
there's a lot of stuff oh my goodness
that is so funny of course no one wants
that
yeah that's actually valuable market
research for kmart and target yeah
what people just wouldn't even want if
it was free yeah take those off the
shelves
people should be paying you for this
kind of research i'm telling you
so um andrew
coming right congratulations first of
all you've signed a deal with absolutely
tim and eric's production company first
of all that's got to be like a dream
partner for you how's that
uh how did that come about it was crazy
because like i was on the one yard line
with a different production company
in in like la area and i was about to
sign a deal
i'm not gonna say it was as i can't but
it was like definitely not like an ideal
situation and then so we were probably a
week from getting that paperwork signed
and i got a dm from eric
oh [ __ ] he was like it was like hey he
was like hey man you want to make a show
and i was like what what i was in a
hotel room in vegas
at this alien uh conference and i was
like yeah here's my number and he called
me and he's like yeah man let's make a
show like as fast as we can like we want
to pick you up right now
like dave and tim and holy [ __ ]
bro so that's how it goes down i was
wondering how it goes down with uh
how those guys pick you up i think that
on like the high level of people who
just do whatever they want it's all like
text message casual i think you get in
that mid-level it's all like pitch
meetings and
right like this web of agents and stuff
like that
so you never pitched anything no pitch
decks none of that [ __ ] it was just
tim
hey let's go eric eric oh yeah air oh it
was eric
yeah what a like i never pitched
anything
that's amazing um well your work really
speaks for itself
and thanks they saw it
so where are you guys in the stages
right now of developing the show or can
you not talk about it
i mean it's coming along like
coronavirus has definitely shut down
like what would be necessary for like a
production team so i've just been
i live in an rv with my two best friends
and i have been doing that for nine
months
so we just travel around to drive
wherever we want make videos like i'm
still doing that we just drove to
portland for those protests we're going
to sturgis bike week in south dakota in
a few days
and we're driving to la i might get an
apartment for a bit
can't wait to watch the portland cover
yeah oh man it's so nuts
like it was crazy because like i
interviewed the feds like i walked up to
the feds like on the line
and i just like put the mic on him and
this fed was like
i was like hey what's your name like who
do you work for and then like they never
talk and then after like 10 questions he
was like i appreciate you not shining
your light in my face like the rest of
the guys and i was like holy [ __ ] the
fed just talked and like all the press
were looking at me like he just got the
friend to talk
and i was like oh i was like i was like
can you repeat that i don't know what
else to say i just wanted him to keep
talking and he was like i said i
appreciate that you didn't put the light
in my eyes and i was like one more time
i just
said it like five times that was good
um how did you first start in this
series of all gas no breaks how
what's the genesis for this series well
when i was a teenager i used to like
hitchhike around alone in the country
just travel from state to state and uh i
would bring like a recorder
like a like a voice memo app and i would
hang out at bus stops and
hotels and i would like talk to people
like on the edge of society like kind of
like outlaw types
kind of like deadbeats with bus tickets
that those kind of people just like road
people
and now basically i self-published like
a zine like a storybook
that was the transcriptions of all the
stories that i got on the road
and stuff like that and the book was
called all gas no breaks so it was
originally like a zine it's no longer
available but
i went to this company called doing
things it owns like a bunch of meme
pages and stuff like that
and i was like yo i want to kind of
adapt my like book into a comedic
video series but also journalistic like
new ganzo
type stuff and they were like okay what
do you need and i was like just buy me
like a
rv from the 90s and i've just lived in
the rv since then
that is crazy how do you get up like
to me that seems like how do you get up
the courage to just go out
hit the road like that by yourself
hitchhiking bus stops these these seems
like
like uh takes some measure of bravery or
some lust for adventure or something
that most people don't have where does
that come from
i don't i don't even know man
have you always wanted to do that like
yeah i think when i was little like i
used to always like look at maps
and i would like put my like finger on
like a random point on the map and be
like oh what is that place like and all
that google
go on google images and like look up
pictures of it and be like i'm gonna go
there one day
and then i'm gonna get a horse in
mongolia and i'm gonna go across
the gobi desert and then i'm gonna get
to india and at that point i'm gonna
figure out how to get to europe and i'm
gonna i just always had these crazy
ideas about
like travel writing and stuff did you
ever
at that point think that those things
would lead to good content like was it
in well actually i before i was
kind of right after i was hitchhiking i
never thought about travel as like a
content thing
but then i went to like i went to like
southeast asia and amsterdam like the
typical
19 year old american with some
graduation money and i realized like
damn all people do is just get
[ __ ] up when they travel like you know
what i'm saying they just get go to
different hostels and just slam drinks
and go to sleep
and like it's always like australians
and israelis and argentinians it's like
this
kind of same thing every time and so i
was like man i just want to travel the
u.s
you know because there's so much to
learn here and it's when i started
exploring america and not
internationally that i was like
okay there's actually content like right
around me all the time you gotta dive a
little bit deeper
what do your parents do for a living i
mean how i just wondering
what's your background um
oh my mom's a fragrance designer like
she makes perfumes and stuff like that
and sells them
and then my dad's a bartender you know
we just developed a fragrance for we're
making a ca
it's it's a total tangent but i thought
you might appreciate it being the son of
a fragrance
maker we developed a you know you know
uh gwyneth paltrow's goop she made this
smells like my vagina candle
the yoni stuff i don't know it has a
spiritual name it was like yes oh yeah
i think isn't yo any like the like
conscious
i don't even want to talk about it yeah
the conscious life that spell
yeah yeah yeah it was like they were
selling something related to gwyneth
paltrow that was
yeah she she gets all the cuckoo uh all
the cuckoo stuff but she made a candle
called it smells like my vagina
and so i made i developed a candle
to uh contrast hers called it smells
like my butthole
and we developed a we developed a really
good [ __ ] smell
and we and we put in a candle so that's
coming this holiday season that's an
announcement here today
exclusive how did you get the uh the
scent from your butthole
you know well we didn't sample my
butthole we went to the laboratory
and we went to the top scientists mines
in the country
had them developed because they i said
look i don't want something that's just
like
smells like your typical like sulfur ass
i need something that's like a little
musty
a little pubie not like i need the whole
package and so i think they really
delivered on that
it's a general [ __ ] smell not mine in
particular so it's just a generic anus
candle
yes okay i'll be purchasing
i tried to get the i tried to get pubes
in it
i wanted to put little black threads in
the wax but everyone vetoed they thought
it was too gross
yeah but i my theory and you you tell me
because you
i mean you're a worldly man if you're
going all out
on an [ __ ] scented candle you might
as well throw the pubes in there
that's all gas snow breaks yeah i've
always said that
so since we're talking about i just i
want to just shout out liam he was a
fan of the podcast he was the guy who
reached out to us he's he's the
fragrance
maestro and he's probably watching right
now so how did that happen
he just reached out and was like hey you
guys yeah you said it yeah you said it
as a joke on the show
and he emailed me and he was like uh
that's what i do
[Laughter]
so sick so um
what do your parents think about it i
feel like my parents would be
terribly nervous and scared for me all
the time
do you think i'm 23 now and i've been
doing stuff like this for like
maybe five or six years i probably
started hitchhiking when i was about 17
and just like doing dangerous american
travel when i was pretty young
so i don't think that i kind of broke
them in a long time ago
i mean it's kind of like when there's a
bad kid he's like
really shitty when he's like 11. by the
time he's 17 his parents like kick him
out you know i mean they just don't give
a [ __ ]
you say quote dangerous do you find that
it's dangerous so have you found any
what's has anything crazy happen you
were like oh man this probably isn't
safe
out hitchhiking and traveling the road
dude straight up like
only college environments because okay
let's say like
you're at a like a conference like you
can get your press pass revoked they'll
just be like hey please leave or if
you're at a football game
security will just say hey get out of
here dude like when i've done shoots at
like university of alabama and in
michigan
like if the top dog of the frat house
like pulls your
bro card like you can get like your ass
kicked that's the only times i've ever
been in danger is like uh
that's so funny probably the university
of alabama football game
i guess word got around that i wasn't
like from there and i was like a west
coast guy or something and that was just
in the streets yeah dude i mean people
know especially my college content is
like always sort of like
shocking humor so they're like hey this
guy's making fun of us
let's basically let's take him out and
he might be a liberal and then before
you
oh no the worst crime of all yeah
so tell me what happened why did you
feel in danger just because
i mean those are the people who can
fight
in the streets without going to prison
you know those are the people who
are jacked up on testosterone and feel
like entitled to like
you know providing so nothing particular
happened you just were got around you
got spooked and got out of there
no i've just had people to grab the mic
from me right
you know what i mean be like oh you want
this like that kind of aggressive
[ __ ] i've had people start fighting each
other while we've been filming
one time i was at university of alabama
and like this this kid came up
he was like this rich jordanian kid i
guess he was the son of a coca-cola
executive i didn't realize this
he starts like freestyling and he's like
yo sing
barely even coherent words and this
other bro comes up with like a trump hat
and he's like he's like you can't
[ __ ] you can't [ __ ] rap for [ __ ]
and then the dude was like [ __ ] you and
then
i don't know what happened but they
started just like fighting and i was in
between them with the microphone and
then mike went flying and it became like
a 20 person brawl
it's on patreon yeah i'm gonna say you
know what i gotta get on patreon because
uh
i've seen all your videos and i haven't
seen that
yeah it's called roll tide episode one
i'll check that out man that sounds like
good
content so here you
are this is your rv i guess you can't
see it but the people can see it
so you really cruise around in this
coachman rv this is your
you live in this with three with two
other dudes yeah
two other dudes yeah i've been living in
it since last since august 15th
2019 now that you're working for
absolutely you might your ass might be
flying
your ass might be flying i prefer to
live in the rv but
my ass might be flying yeah your ass
might be flying now
man you changed bro i'm insane you're
going hollywood
i missed the audience i'm gonna get the
la apartment and change up
hot tub jet ski lifestyle
so are the two dudes you said they're
best friends
they're the ones that just together you
guys make all the videos
yeah it's my high school bff college bff
evan and nick the best of both worlds
the best friends in the world
so how do you guys delegate your duties
how are is it just the three of you
working on the show
yeah definitely so who does what
nick does the camera work exclusively
and some of the editing
evan does like the producing so he like
will call up people and get the press
passes he also runs audio and second
camera and release forms
oh that's why i do all the interviewing
and then like
the far majority of the editing it's
really oh you do
you do a lot of the editing almost all
of it yeah wow
the editing is a beautiful thing my dude
i mean inspired by tim and eric i would
assume right are there at least that
whole
genre yeah vic burger
yeah vic is the man that guy's the
editing god dude
yeah big inspiration um
so what is it like living in an rv with
three dudes i mean i i gotta imagine
there's some logistical issues that
arise from that
can you think of some logistical issues
i could address each one okay
masturbation
walmart uh
you drip off in walmart possible yeah
you go in the bathroom with jerkball
and where do you swear do you not in the
toilet in the sink
that's not it depends you know it's a
day by day thing
[Laughter]
because i i mean obviously you got young
three young men
on the road together i mean it's got to
be
an issue yeah it's actually not that
much
i mean we're not always in the rv at the
same time there is times where you're
alone in the rv okay
you guys put up a sign if the rv is
well usually you would say if it's a
rock and don't come and knock but i
wouldn't assume that anyone's jerking it
that furiously
i mean you got to just figure out when
your your friends are not going to be
in the rv like oh we're going to
starbucks i know that's 15 minutes
done like when the parents used to leave
the house and [ __ ] so is there a toilet
and shower in there or yeah so there is
a toilet but we don't use it because
there was an incident that happened in
tucson so
our septic tank for i'm gonna give you a
history of the septic tank of the rv
real quick because there's two
critical stories to understand so we
bought this rv it hadn't been driven in
like 10 years
turns out the person from massachusetts
is a retired firefighter based on the
stickers that were left on the rv big
firefighter shits were all over the rv
septic tank
it turned into like a brick of [ __ ] that
i guess was like condensed and like
fossilized mummified is a better word
over the years
and um we had a friend over we're in
reno
whatever our home girl was in the rv and
you know you're not supposed to just
[ __ ] in someone's rv but it's also
awkward to tell someone not to [ __ ] in
the rv if you don't know them that well
you said i don't want to just cover up
like hey don't [ __ ] because you assume
that no one is just going to go and take
a crazy dump in your rv bathroom
so like i go out to get like a coffee or
something when i come back and i'm like
oh where's the where's the home yet
oh my god [ __ ] in the rv because i knew
me me and my friend like oh no no oh god
no she comes out
and dude it was an outhouse in there so
we had to get it
cleared in las vegas by like an rv
septic specialist
he said he had to take two power drills
from both sides
and just like like drill into this [ __ ]
brick until it was like a fine dust that
could be like
wow that's [ __ ] story one
[ __ ] story two was in tucson we got
caught slip and started taking more
shits in it because you
once one person takes the [ __ ] in the rv
it's like
all civility's off and people just start
going for it you know i don't know why
well tell me does it just smell what's
the problem with [ __ ] in the rv
toilet does it just this
it just [ __ ] sits there [ __ ] sits there
we typically are in the southwest where
it's hot so that desert heat
heats up the septic tank and the fumes
come rocketing out of like the uh
the toilet hole and they just come
straight to the driver's seat
so you guys kind of just hot box your
own rv
was [ __ ] so this second [ __ ] story is
worse so we're in tucson right there's
this neighborhood called like barrio
anita it's a super cute like
adobe neighborhood north of downtown
we're rolling around
and my friend sees out of the side
mirror that our septic is we call it hot
shotting is
spraying [ __ ] out of the side of the rv
onto people's cars
and all that and we're right outside of
our friend's house we're like oh she's
gonna be so [ __ ] pissed if we don't
figure out this [ __ ]
so we're like oh my god you know what we
have to just dump this illegally so he's
like we're like we have no option
hit her right we go into this like dark
parking lot we think it's like all good
perfect to dump it's so dark so we just
pull the lever
and like 50 gallons of [ __ ] comes out
and we're like
oh man like we feel so bad but whatever
it's just an abandoned parking lot
because we couldn't see anything so our
friend puts the flashlight on it
and it just says elementary school for
the deaf and blind we're like
oh my god no it felt so bad
we're like holy [ __ ] so we actually
brought like buckets over and
cleaned up our own [ __ ]
so do you guys use the toilet to this
day or are that strictly off limits
uh well hydrated pee can go in there
yeah
oh so you guys you guys even have you
guys say if you're dehydrated we don't
even pee in this one
i don't think we say that but it's more
of an unspoken thing
that rv life is no joke so what do you
so you guys generally try to stop off
and [ __ ] like a gas station or something
like that
gas station is always the move you know
but then again i don't like i like when
it's one stall
and not multiple stalls because the
people who shoot at gas stations are
gross
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
share that experience with anyone
yeah truckers especially some of the
truckers at pilot flying j truck stops
are like
[ __ ] kings how does your coffee
affect that kind of lifestyle covid yeah
i had south by southwest in cancun
and then it was like one night
everything in austin closed down all of
our favorite bars shut down
and so we drove from austin to seattle
in three days to quarantine
we just like went from having a great
time to just like 12 hours of driving a
day
and the most boring month of my life wow
i got so bored that i was recording
rap music that's what i was getting i
was freestyling into my computer over
like
50 instrumentals that's how weird it was
yeah
did anything good come with that any
fire songs
yeah no
well you're out there now you're doing
your thing it doesn't seem like covet
has slowed you down at all
it has because you know we we ordinarily
would be covering a bunch of events
every month and it's led to everything
getting canceled basically
so i don't know the coronavirus lockdown
protest it's one of my favorite videos
we did that and we did minneapolis and
now we've just been covering people
not social distancing and stuff like
that yeah it kind of makes for good
content though in a way doesn't it
especially because no other journalists
are out here doing it
they're not willing they're not they
literally can't because they're
sponsored by
organizations that won't give them the
green light right
do you have any of you guys suspected
that you've caught it because you're in
these situations and you're always
wearing masks and being responsible but
the people around you are not and they
say masks
protect other people from you not
necessarily you from other people
you know i think that i had it in texas
back in march
but i quarantined for three weeks and
then i tested a negative
we get tested pretty pretty frequently
so no
i have to because i mean i don't want to
give it to anybody and i'm always around
old people
do you how do you get tested when you're
crossing the country do you find that
it's easy to get tested because that's
something
that's obviously urgent care is like 175
bucks
boom that's what i do whenever i feel
like i have been around a large i'm
about to do it tomorrow
after portland that's smart you're very
responsible i like that about you
thanks um
dude when you enter a room or an event
you have this
knack you have like for finding the
weirdest wildest person in the room
tell me about your process of like
finding the right person to talk to
because you know like in florida man
you you'll just you'll see someone
walking on the street like that one dude
in the short shorts and just like
correct me if i'm understanding the
situation wrong but you just saw this
dude on the street and pulled over and
like yo dude let's chat
yep how do you what do you say to him to
initiate the combo
i don't know certain things i just just
do
i guess like um how do you explain who
you are what do you say
hey man i'm making a documentary the
thing about characters is that they love
to be on camera they don't care what
you're doing i remember like i'll tell
them
this is all gas no breaks and we'll
finish the thing on the like what was it
what was it called again yeah they don't
even
they don't even care and if you go into
a convention
any every funny enthusiastic person is
going to run towards the camera and just
start going nuts
it still it seems like you have a talent
to
get them to feel comfortable because
they they just seem like they don't care
they let you record everything
um i love these people because i think
your
style is i don't know if you're familiar
with louis thoreau
the documentarian but he has a similar
style where
um he's very unjudgmental and very
passive and accepting of all people as
strange as they are
and like that makes people feel very uh
welcome and open
and he gets the best interviews out of
people i feel like you share that
characteristic with him
yeah i do this one thing that he does
that i kind of got from watching him
where even if you know the answer to
something you still ask it
you just act sort of naive and curious
right totally
like like do you if you're like a mega
rally or something you're like hey why
do you support trump like you kind of
know what they're gonna say
in a way but you just you keep oh wow
interesting like you just keep going
keep probing he does that like he's a
smart dude
he'll go into contexts where he knows
he'll go to like a west borough baptist
church and say
how do you feel about you know gay
people you say stuff like where he knows
the answer and i'm like
why and he just keeps that's really
smart and like
not a lot of journalists do that a lot
of journalists operate on this like i
already know thing therefore i'm going
to ask like a level
five question like insane question
because i already know the base levels
but
he keeps cool he's such an inspiration
he's a genius yeah i love him
he really is i i am i find that
sometimes when you ask that base level
like level one question
you what you actually get when you think
you knew the answer
surprises you that's actually a really
good point you know
that happens all the time yeah
especially it's conspiracy conventions
where everyone's got their own little
crazy thing like the flat earth
conference the disagreements among
different bullet points of the flat
earth model is crazy man
are those are those some of the wildest
people you've met because that
that can that's one of the conspiracies
that you really have to suspend
like such a level of disbelief in your
mind that you're pretty much willing to
accept
anything that i would say they're the
scariest people i've met
really in what way dude that that shit's
all about jews
i was i noticed that that was that how
was it that the jews are behind
round earth like damn can we get a break
i actually the idea is that jews control
all the money
the idea and nasa gets a bunch of money
for space projects but the money for the
space projects because there is no space
because the earth is flat
goes into the pocket of nasa and then
funnels back up into this global jewish
banking system so it's just a giant
money laundering scheme
yeah it's giant money laundering scheme
and it's all about the earth and the
shape of it that's
that is the basis of the decision the
whole flat earth thing just
because it's like why would people go
through such an extreme measure of
convincing the entire
world just to launder some money there's
got to be better ways
hey man i mean you're talking about flat
earthers here
they're like you know self-proclaimed
skeptics you know like i don't believe
with the lies it's like but you believed
that the earth was flat because someone
on facebook told you yeah
i just don't understand like this new
generation of like
i guess not new generation but like
emboldened movement of like right-wing
skeptics
right they believe the most insane [ __ ]
ever there is a conspiracy to anything
it does seem like most skeptics slash
conspiracy theorists are tend to be
right wink and i don't know why that is
uh yeah there's like
right i mean it seems like the that
conspiratorial paranoid thinking tends
to lead
to the right maybe because they're like
they're in support of gun
gun [ __ ] right and also like the woke
left like kind of those conscious
influencers like uh they believe in like
chemtrails and 5g
oh do they yeah well i wasn't aware of
that
yeah i was the flat earth one i noticed
two things
there was a common thread hating jews
and rapping
why are so many flat earthers rappers
dude
every one in five people has some bars
is that so interesting dude tell me the
truth do you ask people if they have
raps when you're interviewing them
yes yeah yeah it's like why is everyone
you talk to
rapping dude that's genius it's genius
though
it's so funny oh it's so fun
do you find it i find it ironic also
that a lot of people who
have quote bars tend to be
like for example look at like the lady
who was at the don
the don jr
but like she's out there rapping right
and then you go oh are you a fan of
hip-hop
no hell no hell no what is that
um she doesn't like hip-hop because
she's racist
yeah but she raps so yeah but i mean
i don't know man we're talking
birmingham alabama suburbs right now
like i don't know where you get there
but like
that was crazy she didn't ask me to rap
she tried to sell me her mixtape and i
was in disbelief i'm at the donald trump
junior book signing and this like 80
year old lady named pam was like would
you like to buy my mixtape
what what where are we like that was one
of my favorites
hold that's a number that's the uh
fourth or the third clip let's watch
that
so she um is that how she initiated the
conversation with you she was trying to
sell you a mixtape
yes damn but she doesn't like hip-hop i
mean guys
think about this think about it god damn
it he goes no i like elvis
conway to indeed the country classics i
was like holy [ __ ]
she gave me her cd it has one song and
it's like
the only cd in my car and so every time
the radio is not working
someone always pressures the cd option
that's oh my god
here he is her husband looks like a
elvis impersonator
you know what is this guy for real this
guy right here tonight to get a book and
to give this to don junior
oh man it's a special day can i see this
this is a rap song
and i wrote it yes and it's been playing
on the rick and bubba show
so what's your name little p what does p
stand for
pam glass we are trump supporters down
to the bone so this
is the reason i wrote this song so
listen to what i've got to say and he'll
make america
great one day vote trump yeah baby vote
trump
he's a businessman with a presidential
plan sent down here to
heal our land so when you hear this
funky sound you're gonna know that trump
is around he only wants save for all
this is why he has them built in the
wall
he's brought our jobs back around and
put our feet on solid ground
so don't you listen to the lies they say
cause trump is making us great today
anyway it just keeps going on and on and
in the background
wait keep playing oh
so tell me how your rap career started
riding down the road
just thinking about it yeah thank you so
much for rapping
are you a big fan of the hip-hop genre
not really
but i am a big trump supporter if you
had to pick who are your three favorite
rappers
i don't have any rappers we don't listen
to rap
it's incredible how her husband's hair
is so black
at that age yeah all-natural
um i wanted to show these kids
god these all these people are so wild
in this video at
the book signing man how do you find for
example this
specific event in such a specific
location
uh i don't even know i guess we just
like look up events like
we kind of know where we're going to
drive we can look along the route like
oh
let's start driving from like miami to
texas would be like oh georgia events
louisiana events you just kind of look
for stuff that's along the route and we
figure it out
and we got blessed with that don junior
book reading
that was so epic his girlfriend was
there i mean this was like a serious
official event right
i know i interviewed her a second time
and just like didn't remember who i was
oh yes
i was like i was like casually speaking
are you dating don jr and she was like
yes and i was just like
she's like no seriously she got
coronavirus oh she did
yeah recently at a trump event what's
her name again
something kimberly guilfoyle yeah um
i want to show you these kids because i
did a double take i was like wait did i
hear that right
here that's trump 2020 you feel me
epstein didn't kill himself
hey drain the swamp trump uh gaze for
trump what's your favorite thing about
trump
oh honestly i think it's because he's
racist that's your favorite thing about
him
yeah bro what
i was like did i hear that right there
you have it somebody said it
i think he was trolling but you know
specific kind of like
troll yeah um has
has all these uh road trips around
america changed your outlook on america
at all
yeah definitely well it's so crazy
because
i was hopeful when i first hit the road
and then i became super like nihilistic
after just going to all these crazy
events and seeing how like lost a lot of
people are
and stuff like that but then the way
our audience has grown maybe hopefully
again
that makes sense yeah yeah it does and
like how many people are responding to
this like
sort of ethnography that we're doing
definitely
i would find it very difficult not to
become kind of jaded or nihilistic
i mean there's definitely that vive vibe
conveyed although you're really kind of
rubbing shoulders with
the fringes the absolute fringe of
society so
like when see i've not really traveled
these areas that you frequent like you
know this
a lot of the midwest southern places
are people generally all like this no
definitely not actually you get crazier
types on the coasts i mean
think about every type of person is in
california and the wet i can't think of
it
you got there's rednecks in california
there's the looks there's burners
every dude california you know there's
places on the west coast have a greater
diversity of personalities
but if you want a concentration of
people like that like you just saw
you're probably better off in the south
but most people are just living
you know they're not going to don
junior's book signing
to celebrate triggered you know uh as i
understand it
your first big hit with all gas no
brakes was your burning man video is
that correct
yeah those are just the first videos
period i don't know if it was the first
smash hit but it was the first videos so
was it an immediate hit the burning man
not immediate but i think it went pretty
hard i don't know where
our growth's been pretty steady but
trying to think of the most explosive
stuff that we made
the reason yeah you're kind of right
burning man was pretty good i mean the
recent stuff went off really hard like
your recent fourth of july
yeah celebrate our first like three
million view youtube video
yeah that's awesome but the burning man
video a lot of people
wanted to sue you for that video right
yeah particularly that one dude dj soft
baby i don't know if any of you guys
were able to catch that before it went
down
oh yeah i'll tell you how this happened
because this is really funny i think i
can speak about it because i'm not using
his government name
so this dude rich guy from massachusetts
walking around
with just gold leggings and no shirt on
like
basically walking around i noticed
because there's like soup kitchens that
burning man where people go at all hours
of the night to get free food
there was this chowder spot you know in
the playa there
and he kept running up to the the chef
and being like oh this is so
[ __ ] good like he was like this is
the best life
like melting down and i was like that
dude is so high on molly so i went up to
him and i was like
hey man like you want to be in a
documentary and he was like
and then uh he came over he was like you
know going all crazy and he we just
did this interview about like molly is
like a therapeutic thing it was really
funny
he was just like don't be doing some
[ __ ] moon rocks you find on the
ground and he was just like being really
funny
started dancing with the shirt off for
like 20 minutes just this awesome
dancing
he signed a release form i believe
something like that it was all good
so we leave burning man we post a video
and like
within i think two hours like not only
is the post down but like the page is
down
and the ip address has been like flagged
so like
it was terrifying we thought the whole
thing was over
wow that was one of our first videos
moral of the story is burning man's a
hard place to film
because a lot of those people were like
high paid silicon valley
you know tech types they go to burning
man's be crazy but
they're not as crazy as they seem there
yeah yeah that was a legal nightmare
actually
i probably would not go back to burning
man again to film that's crazy
so wait you've posted the video where
did you post it
where it was removed instagram instagram
and with two hours it was shut down huh
and you ended up in litigation with this
guy too no definitely not
i mean i think he was content with it
being taken down
and then you just edited him out and put
it back up yeah but that that's one of
my favorite clips of all time that sucks
oh yeah we gotta is that resurface
somewhere on the internet
blink twice if i could find that on the
internet
there you go that's what's up dude um
so do you prepare like release forms and
you have everyone sign it when you
record them
yeah we do most of the time i mean we
learned our lesson a few times
one time in alabama i had these these
girls like
college girls like came on camera and
they were just like i would let trump
like
[ __ ] on my face like all this crazy
trump stuff is just like i love trump
they're like i would even let baron
trump hit it
i post that and then had lawsuit threats
i had private investigators with alabama
area codes harassing my mom
what you got my family's phone number
they're harassing my family damn
oh my god yeah release forms are crucial
now
more with college students because they
have they have more growing to do and
they have more to lose
we don't get release forms from like
people in their
40s and 50s who are at you know music
festivals they don't sue you unless
they're like obviously rich
it's the kids parents who sue right 18
to 18 to 22 year olds their parents will
stew the [ __ ] out of you do you find
that well in the example of this guy you
the dj babyface or whatever you had the
release form right
uh it's possible but it's also possible
we didn't i don't really remember but
either way
really you can't if you work hard enough
you can avoid a release form by saying
that you were on drugs right
right yeah yeah yeah it's a hard case to
make but you can definitely make the
case if your lawyers are good
consent at the time at the time he was
super stoked on it
well that's the that definitely is the
effect of md that's funny though man
do you find that i i i have to imagine
that a lot of these interviews
either go wrong or at a certain point
maybe people cat you catch a lot of [ __ ]
after the fact when people go hey this
guy's kind of
making fun of me actually so do you have
ever p
do you have any stories of like people
contacting you directly and talking to
them or is it just kind of the weird
problem honestly it's been happening
less and less because i'm trying to move
the brand further away from like gotcha
type [ __ ] where i seem super legitimate
and it ends up being like a meme thing
i'm trying to get more towards like not
overly political but i want to make it
so when i pull up somewhere and people
recognize me
they don't think that i'm going to only
make fun of them they see that i
might do some making fun of them but i
also want to get what they're saying
across so like i don't want i want to
have some duality where i can't be
pigeonholed as like a borat bruno type
where it's like this is a troll
right because that will end up like
harming it when you're trying to shoot
and people recognize you
yeah are you worried about a day when
maybe let's say you make a show with
appso and it becomes like
like a big show are you worried that it
might prevent your ability to catch
interviews
no because it actually makes more people
be down to interview because people love
the show like for example when
i was in portland there was a bunch of
like antifa protesters
they never do interviews with anyone but
because they were fans of my minneapolis
content i got like five or six
interviews with people in full black
block gear like telling me their demands
so i got a lot of [ __ ] that otherwise
wouldn't have been possible without the
fan base
yeah that's kind of a really great
thread through your story because i feel
like with a lot of people like you you
name like borat sasha bear cohen's
character
because because he specifically lampoons
people if they know him there's like i'm
not going to participate
but in your case i think you're right
that that people will be encouraged if
they know who you
are yeah i mean if everyone in the
marquette
michigan fourth of july video knew who
we were every person that's
why i knew i saw a lot of people
referencing your name and your show and
stuff
yeah i mean dude sam's working on our
advantage and if it doesn't i'll just
get a buzz cut or something
right yeah there's always that option
rebrand bro i used to have hair just
like you when i was in high school
where'd you grow up uh in ventura
california you don't know where it's
near l.a suburban valley kind of
but i use i got like a gnarly dandruff
bro and i had to get rid of it
you have that problem no not so much
anymore because i got the hair and
shoulders but there was a time man
especially in my high school years i was
flaked out
flanked out bro i was snowing on
everybody
man yeah i got the head and shoulders
too i wasn't cutting it but i use
i actually rock head and shoulders to
this day so weird
so where do you guys live in la i'm
trying to find like an area to rent an
apartment and it's like that's cool
uh we live in west los angeles is that
right dan i mean technically
yeah so i mean anywhere in la is great
yeah you know
yeah uh you just as long as you're
preparing for
having to drive places you know i'm
going to buy a car i'm pretty sure
when they get down there
yeah i feel like anywhere is is good i
think you
i think you find a nice a lot of nice
places you'll probably be working i know
there
there are offices in like burbank or
something so there's a lot of
things yeah weird i think there's a lot
of nice places around there
valley do you do you know how um those
two guys
those three guys really dave eric and
tim would be involved in
and the production of of a show you make
with them
ah no i've never done this
yeah yeah for editing helping with
editing and just you know being there
i mean they're really good references
like uh they're just awesome there's
some legends man
um i was wondering about your videos
it feels so effortless but
it makes me wonder does it sometimes
happen when you go somewhere and you
feel like you can't get
the right footage or it's not
interesting enough or
yeah it happens all the time yeah
definitely had a couple shoots that we
weren't able to make a video out of
just a matter of not getting down on
yourself especially
during this quarantine time it's got to
be frustrating right like
i've been there like i'll make a video i
know that feeling you like if i find a
really good topic and then i just
i try so hard to make it work but it
just doesn't work
and i i can see like yeah but you you
drive to a place you go
you do it i mean like what's an example
of a video that you guys attempted that
didn't work out that you put a lot of i
think that we did the
the way we did the border security expo
video didn't work very well
i liked that video yeah yeah i just
didn't like it because it was just so
heavy on editing and music
yeah yeah you feel like there's no way i
had this area where like i was like i'll
we'll salvage a lot of these clips by
like blasting them with meme music
and now it's like i want to get back to
that like original raw thing of like no
music minimal editing
that's the [ __ ] i love your interviewing
technique when you interview people
i've noticed this would you put a mic in
someone's face you don't have to say
anything
and you i don't say anything dude i love
that that you just nod
very affirming like i'm with you all the
way dude
i'm like you know what i mean hell yeah
and you just put the mic in their face
man and like
they'll say something eventually like i
i forgot what video was but uh
i was i think was the area 51 where
there was the two officers
and the one the second officer didn't
want to say anything but you just put
the mic in his face
yeah he just started nodding and he just
he was forced he had to say something
it was awesome i love it i just did it
to the feds in portland like i said it
was pretty
and it worked right i mean it worked it
worked
what are some is there any memorable
moments on the road of stuff you had to
cut that was too wild
so i went to the avn expo in uh vegas
and i made really good friends with
these two
actors which is sean lawless and kendra
cox and uh
like we sort of started joking like who
writes the scripts for story-based
porn movies you know because some of the
setup is just so bad
and i wonder who is you know assigned to
create the drama that leads to like the
porn scene
so they let me write like a script for
them
and i wrote the script and i actually
played the distressed husband and then
shot
kendra was my wife and sean was the
cable guy who was sent to fix the uh the
tv that was broken because circuit city
sold us a defective tv and i wanted to
watch uh the emoji movie
so i just made this crazy plotline um
that's on pornhub only it is yeah
oh that's great what's the title i think
it's like nerdy suit man
gets wiped banged by big [ __ ] cable guys
this man gets banged by a cable guy
or dirty suit man let's start with that
one
man porn you said it's on pornhub let's
take a look
nerdy suit man's bbw wife [ __ ] by big
[ __ ]
hell yeah i think that might be it i
just want to see the
setup i wrote the whole thing this is
awesome dude
here i'll play the audio oh my god
oh [ __ ]
i've had the longest day at work let me
this is one let me get this straight
you guys were at the avn and you're just
like let's go shoot a porno in your
hotel room that's what it looks like
yeah well i would just make i was
interviewing them about script writing
and i was like they're like do you want
to do it i was like like write a script
for the porno i was like
an x-ray in the porno but not nude you
can add that to your um
to your imdb writing credits bro
let me get let me get a picture of him
he's a huge porn star let me see his
face
oh yeah i've seen him so many times bro
there you go all gas no breaks you even
got the title credit man
oh my gosh oh so you're there the whole
time while they're [ __ ]
your dad watch your board oh dude
no so he's interviewing them as they're
having sex
she's riding him absolutely look where
we are
how about you are your parents proud
really nice view from the window too
actually what does this tattoo mean is
yeah my ex-boyfriend put it back there
it's probably going to be a hard
question but what's the worst decision
you've ever made
i don't really have too many bad
decisions i think uh
so his [ __ ] is she's in her right now
she's writing she knows
what about you man what's your biggest
regret in life but i didn't do this
sooner
yeah i worked the desk job and it sucked
i worked 40 hours a week
making dick money and they're stuck
everybody awesome i realized
i could have been doing this the whole
time
and i like big tits and big ass and i
like big women and she ain't a lady
unless she's 180 all gas no brakes
there you have it i wonder like was it
all worth it
[Music]
okay well that there's your one episode
that can only be found
on pornhub pornhub exclusive
uh what was it like being on set during
a porn
but i guess it wasn't really on set it
looks like it was just two people
[ __ ] in a hotel room kind of
it was gross was it it looked kind of
gross
wasn't it it's kind of gross
you look horrified because the cameraman
were also
head butters i don't know i don't know
anyone knows that
wait your cameraman got popped a woody
no it's not his cameraman
the cameraman work with the adult he had
a
woody yeah they always do no way i
thought you would get desensitized
and his he's just got a boner bulging in
his pants
yeah that's nars bro so weird did you
comment on it
no i just stuck out of my mind i feel
like
i wish we got a comment from him maybe
he was the husband of the girl oh
he was filming it oh so that's like okay
i guess
yeah i guess i guess that's a little bit
more forgivable yeah
yeah it's very forgivable he was mad
cool too he was like wasted
he's awesome he's like i can't wait to
watch this [ __ ]
okay yeah dude get it that makes sense
it's his thing yeah that's his thing god
bless us
um do you
i gotta get over to patreon man it
sounds like all the good shit's over
there
what's your patreon where how do we find
you all gas no breaks on patreon
yeah you have a lot of support there man
uh dude
it's it's amazing when i went over there
the amount of uh support you guys over
there is fantastic i'm very happy for
you
i was just i was having the mic in your
face moment but it wasn't working
going to be in the same room i think
oh there was this so i want to watch
some clips together okay
some some parts that stuck out to me
what do you make of these people who are
protesting the the lockdown
aren't you closed i closed it guys
well as as we can see
we're having a second wave now because
of the people who refuse to
follow the guidelines at first so and
trump's wearing a mask
a lot of people are dying dude herman
cain died today
herman cain died he died today and you
know what what
he got covered from the tulsa [ __ ]
rally bro
what i said my camera crew was out there
holy [ __ ] he went to herman cain died
from the tulsa rally
yes herman cain her owner of little
caesars
yes you know that he wait he owns little
seizures
his family has a part ownership of
little caesar's pizza i know he was the
ceo of some pizza company
maybe i'm wrong about that maybe that's
fully inferred information
i'd like to think that herman cain is
the ceo of little caesars he know he
owns some pizza place i don't think it's
a little
seizures hermes seizures
my god well i've been saying little
seizures for a while
it's just fun saying it because it
herman cain
pizza pizza business
he owned some pizza [ __ ] i never heard
of like uh
it's called uh this is important
godfather's pizza what some
are not little caesars anyway he went to
the tulsa rally he proudly posted a
picture of him without a mask with his
whole possum oh my god
and now he died of covid it does yeah
this is happening
i think a lot of those people who were
at the um
at the coroner's lockdown protest they
just fall victim to information circles
you know these are like pretty
concentrated facebook groups they're
echo chambers
i always say that you know when the
internet first came out the idea was
that we're going to have a more
well-informed public
that was going to have access to ideas
in the left right middle whatever but
really
just seems to create like different
bubbles of people like on the far right
far left
and the people at the coronavirus
lockdown protest for very much
right-wing conspiracy queuing on flat
earth or
types they only communicate with each
other so there's the question of how
much are they falling victim
to this and how much are they
antagonizing it
it's a hard one to think about i mean
yeah it's pretty sad
i mean once people actually start dying
i don't i don't have any will against
them i mean no me neither no
i know totally it's totally sad and
actually it's how i see it happening a
lot now a lot of these cove truthers are
catching the virus and
they're dying although i think it would
bring people together because
it's just it's a this virus is like a
common enemy
we all have to fight the same thing
yeah i kind of lost a lot of faith in
our institution
and just the fabric of our society when
something like a pandemic can become a
political issue it just
it just struck me as so bizarre and you
know now we're in this
situation where people are desperate to
reopen schools
and reopen the economy but like we if we
just did it right the first time we'd be
all good by now like most
other wealthy countries just friends
that's the thing you said other
countries
it's like people forget that it's global
it's like this isn't just like a trump
versus biden
you know like patriot versus like
snowflake thing
this is like every country so
was it political in italy no it's not
in israel it's not i don't know nowhere
else dude maybe
england maybe brazil these kind of uh
it just seems like like when i was
telling my friends in israel that
there is a whole discussion here about
if you should wear a mask or not they
were like
what yeah well there you go that's crazy
you can't even say that because
over here it's such an issue yeah you
know i was just i was in bismarck north
dakota dude
went past a packed bar with no one
wearing a mask i was like
yeah do you find it odd that people
i see this a lot online that people
blaming the whole
uh you can't even really call it a
second wave it's the first wave
just up but people are blaming the
increase in cases
on protests and i find that really
bizarre
you don't think it could be like related
at all i think
for the most part most studies have
shown that
that the protest didn't play a big part
and i think when you see it on camera
you see wow look at all these people
right
and you think man this is a disaster but
when you compare what was how many
people were at rallies like you know 10
000
20 30 000. when you compare that to the
population of entire
state it's really a drop in the bucket i
mean it's the reopening it's the people
at the bars it's people at the
restaurants
it's people indoors not wearing masks
that are really
spreading the virus you look at a state
like florida how many people live in
florida like 30
million or something like that i don't
know 20 million yeah they're all like
sweating and making out on the beach
at all times right yeah passing joints
and cigarettes and stuff
sharing beers i mean and you're talking
about millions and millions of people so
like if you just it's easy to look at
protesters on the street
like that's they are the specific reason
why we're here but like it really is a
drop in the bucket
and unfortunately george floyd
didn't choose the time to be murdered
right
you had coronavirus too yeah interesting
yeah i also noticed that they tried to
say that's why he died and not the dude
whose knee was dig dug into his neck
oh my god people come up with any reason
other than that why he died
yeah it's amazing we can argue about
anything but and you heard you ever
heard uh george floyd's old music and
that song sitting on top of the world by
big floyd like some old school houston
screwed up click [ __ ]
man george floyd's music was dope he was
a really
like a real legendary rapper in houston
in the 90s you know dj screw like old
school houston [ __ ]
no no well dj's crew was like a pioneer
of like screwed up music in houston
which is like
kind of like codeine influence like
slowed down music like chopped and
screwed
he invented that him and george floyd
whose rap name was big floyd they kicked
it super tough and
big floyd made a bunch of songs and one
of them called sitting on top of the
world
is like the most haunting song because
he really is sitting on top of the world
right now
and i did not hear that check that [ __ ]
out for sure hmm
wow where was this one i want to show
you this moment and
when you're at the rally to protest the
lockdown
and a dude comes up to you and coughs in
your face
yeah sort of he more coughs in another
dude's face oh yeah
here it is and i am bouncing off the
walls of my living room because i can't
go out
california not communism everybody cough
in my face
do it somebody come cough in my face yes
puff directly in your face yeah i'm not
sure this guy just doesn't have a fetish
that he's disguising as being a covet
truther
he's a flat earther too i'm just putting
that out there oh he is
wow i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give him
any free exposure but yeah that dude his
name is jake and he's a flat earther
that doesn't surprise me at all man this
guy
this guy whatever it is he is it is he's
still alive
do you know
no way i never did put on hand sanitizer
ever and i don't ever wash my hands
can you believe that it's like dude okay
we're talking about
like the fact that you don't ever wash
your hands isn't really a debate here
but
it's like yes dude i believe you yeah
you don't have to worry about that
he's like not only is covent fake all
viruses are
fake i have never washed my hands
believe it because it's true
in my opinion we're looking at a
seasonal flu
in a bunch of fake death numbers go
ahead america
touch your face go out and have sex
and don't worry about touching anything
you [ __ ] touch
anything and everything it makes your
immune system
stronger i used to be afraid of raw eggs
and raw meat and now i drink raw eggs
and i eat raw meat
and i have been for years and i'm
[ __ ] fine
everything i don't think so are you yeah
i think this guy's gotta
affected you in some way but wow pretty
sure that guy's got a brain a parasite
what camera what camera do you guys use
is it like i've never heard of this
sorry i'm trying i'm trying to control
this sorry go ahead
is it like old school well we have what
we call big cami which is like a
2004 like shitty giant panasonic that we
bought off this like cuban dad in
kendall florida
and then we have the nice camera which
is like 3 500 bucks which is like a sony
alpha
mm-hmm you guys use like or is it
digital the big one it's digital
yeah the first like crop of digital
cameras to come out
uh it's awesome it looks great
pretty much true 911 was an inside
job no one's ever walked on the moon the
vaccines are poison
can you cough in my face dude
see people are too they're too scared to
even cough when you ask
it's like it's not we don't have it okay
i mean yeah i don't need to argue with
these people
do you remember a lot about the the
people you meet on the streets you seem
to have a keen memory about all of the
people you meet
yep do you have a good memory in general
or do people just stand out to you
i have really good memory i actually
have the best memory
i don't know i don't know i think so i
remember like a lot of people
although i don't think i would forget
these are kind of unforgettable people
you run across
everybody in the videos i remember a lot
about because they made a depression on
me yeah yeah factors into the editing
process
i don't remember like every i'm sure
i've talked to a bunch of people i don't
remember
especially like the furries you know i
actually didn't have a good time at that
conference
tell me it doesn't really come through
certain certain conferences i just like
don't have fun at
i don't know why because they're just
like so overwhelming and
still like stimulating in a way that
it's unfamiliar that i just kind of burn
out
like i was staying at a motel 6 next to
the airport in chicago in december and
like
walking a mile to the furry con every
day and just like
i don't know i just i guess i didn't
know what the furry fandom was about i
thought it was just like a sex thing i
don't know why i thought that
i thought it was like a weird beauty
because thing totally wrong
i think first it's actually pretty cool
and it like a lot of the people there
like
i talked to are like on the spectrum and
so when they wear the fursuit like
it makes they can socialize non-verbally
and don't have to make eye contact so
they can just like
touch and without like having like the
social pressure of like an
eye contact thing so it's actu i think
first it's actually pretty cool and it's
super therapeutic to mad people that i
talk to
so that was the dilemma it's like [ __ ]
i'm not here to make fun of these people
anymore
like what am i supposed to do i don't
want to make these people feel shittier
than they already
have been made to feel before they
became fairies
so i just i don't know i just had a
tough time there i was bored
i think that a lot of people watching
will appreciate hearing that because
we've kind of met we make fun of furries
on this show uh
and we always get a little bit of
blowback from the furry community they
feel that they're misunderstood
it sounds like you've had that came to
that same conclusion
yeah i just think sex is a really small
part of it even though for somebody
to say right seems to be a big part of
the portrayal
which is where i don't know why it just
seems so synonymous with
fetishism i don't know why either
the tale i don't know what's going on
there there's just something that like
makes it seem like it's like a sex cult
yeah well
dude have you been inside a furry suit
because i got one for a gag
and it's i mean the the commitment it
takes to be inside that suit
for more than 10 minutes because it is
not comfortable and it's hot
as a mother yeah i have i know it's like
4 500 bucks but i would actually be a
scaly not a furry because i'm
far more into reptiles than i am animals
with hair and fur
and i had this lizard that died on the
american idol finale in 06 when i was in
seventh grade no that's when i was seven
years old you know when
carrie underwood beat bob ice i was a
huge bob ice fan
so i was already crying because bo bice
lost the american idol finale and then i
go into my room and my lizard snakey is
just like slumped on his back like
dead so i was just the worst day of my
life so i was thinking about getting rip
snakey tattooed but then i met someone
at the furry con who designed
scale-based furry costumes for like
seven thousand dollars
so i wanted to be like an eight foot
tall like buff like reincarnated sneaky
and just
roll around and speak like a lizard
voice
so you so people who are rep who
identify with reptilians
are scalies scalies yeah they kind of
get a bad rap in the furry thing
really it's like the slytherin of
furries you know that's just like why
are you doing that
but you can cr you can roll up in a
scaly suit and people may not accept you
if people are like ah it's the [ __ ]
scaly i don't know why i made them like
philly italians i don't think they talk
like that
but there would be like uh ah you know
the scalies are here
but i find that interesting that there's
different communities i
i guess but they kind of are still in
the furry world right
there's beef too there's hell that's
what i'm curious about yeah what is the
right wing there's kind of right-wing
furries
fairies who have a problem with trans
people there's there's tons of like
weird [ __ ] going on in the furry
community
there's like there's crazy they're not
just furries man politics
because part of the thing is furries are
also non-gendered for the most part
so it's pretty much a safe haven for
anyone struggling with identity
issues at all i mean you can just be
like this very and like
it's tight bro it's not for me like i
don't think i would actually ever
participate
but i respect every furry there you go
furry lives matter
yeah i like that i appreciate i actually
appreciate that insight
yeah uh i do find that useful um
flip flop the clown is is a man who
stuck out to me
from florida man one i what i want to
know first of all let's watch this so i
can
familiarize where are you right now when
you come across
a character like flip flop the clown so
i'm at a place where sometimes i go to
relax
it's called the sausage castle it's
outside of orlando it's ran by a uh
jackass affiliate and juggalo you know
kingpin named mike busey
and it's uh it's where i go when i'm in
florida
just you know chill out for a bit edit
it's like a giant mansion in the swamps
is that why he's in a clown mask because
it's like juggalo affiliated or is this
dude just
like like busy you can look him up he
looks insane i would encourage you to
google it
what's his name mike busey mike busey
yeah he's a friend of mine
so the way um the sausage castle works
is it's like a giant house it's kind of
like a dorm where each person is
basically like an independent
only fans content creator and they pay
the bills for this giant mansion
based upon like a percentage of the
money that's coming in to like
independent
uh like pornographic content creation
basically
huh i've never heard of such a place in
my life yeah here you are
yeah and so i just like a lot of
i have a lot of friends there
they call it the sausage castle because
like that's like vice called it because
there's like so many dudes there
someone called it the sausage castle but
that's where so
that was a halloween party at the
sausage castle last year
and it's called drunk people in costumes
dude the
the dj the celebrities that appeared
were so strange
dj paul from three six mafia uh stitches
the wrapper you guys stitches
and uh daddy longneck was there daddy
long made an appearance
big gucci but it's just like it's crazy
like
it's a really interesting thing by the
way you
yeah i was there they didn't even know
who i was though this is before the show
even popped off i thought it was like a
nerd
little did they know yeah shaq but dude
the sausage castle is a lot
shaq kicks it there post malone kicks it
there although for real oh
this is a wild spot shaq at the sausage
castle
yeah he's every time you go there's like
kind of like
random celebrities so here we have emily
here we have um
flip flop the clown with the foot fetish
uh did you
i'll just let this speak for itself
did you see the uh lead up to this how
did he convince her to do this
oh the girl yeah oh there's my friend
jessica she's from san diego she's
she's recently become like a trump babe
but
at the time oh yeah i know the type the
trump babes yeah like uh
it'll just be like photos of her in like
a bikini on the beach in san diego and
be like i love my country
yeah with like american bikini and
everything yeah
so yeah no she was just down she's
everyone at the sausage castle is like
yeah
man what a vibe yeah um
i liked it but i feel like dirty about
liking it
not as dirty as mouth though oh
flip-flop the clown of a foot fetish
what do you like about feet man i was
born with a foot fetish i just love
the odor and the taste and the ah was
there a certain age where you realize
like hey i like this
yeah when i was a kid i used to
fantasize about
but uh when i was in kindergarten the
kindergarten teacher stomping and
putting me in her shoes and just like me
living inside her shoes and stuff you
know and then i got older and uh you
know i got
boners with the same fantasies in your
life how many times do you think you put
in your mouth
i don't know like somewhere in like uh
almost a million
have a foot fetish rap song called feet
on the face
shut the [ __ ] shut your [ __ ] face
because you know i love the taste
i'm a mother yeah i don't think i've
ever met anyone like this in my life
but here you are he does that all year
round
oh damn coronavirus is really [ __ ]
over flip-flop
oh man i feel bad for him right now he
probably hasn't been able to do that in
a long time maybe he's finding a way i
hope so
i don't think coronavirus is stopping
him a guy like that
yeah but i mean i heard that he's gonna
get like the gathering of the juggalos
and just go ten to ten
and just like oh my gosh he actually has
a he has a gay cousin
who's like flip-flop but you know sucks
on dude's toes only
and they go together to the juggle again
no way they probably clean up at the
juggalo place i can see everybody being
down
there even just for the novelty factor
you know
yeah i've seen him do crazy he was doing
some
way more hardcore [ __ ] than that at the
sausage castle i think he was like
eating an ass on the like he's going
crazy man flip-flop is it
he goes in oh he's just eating straight
up ass so he
yeah that's the first thing i saw him
doing was just eating ass on the
pavement that's amazing
um have you ever had your foot in him
or his cousin's mouth no
no would you
oh okay just curious
i mean oh yeah that's a good question
then the
the other character that that jumped out
to me from florida man
ii of course is joker man who
again is oh that's my boy so what does
he go by joker man
joker gang 305 live south sea south side
saint pete pinellas county in this [ __ ]
that's his full intro
i'm going to say it again yeah yes hey
joker gang 305 rawlish chico live
south side saint pete pinellas county in
this [ __ ]
every single time you see him wow so
this guy says to you joker man's been
hitting up my girl
did he introduce you to joker man how
did you find joker man
i joker gang was viral about two or
three years ago
oh and when he was like in and out of
jail like smoking a ton of crank and
like waving guns at
pedestrians and country clubs and going
back to prison
joker gang kind of fell off got
semi-sober
and he kind of just jumped back on the
map i actually did a solo interview with
joker gang
six months ago and uh he revealed the
origin of his face tattoos
he got it because his girlfriend i guess
aborted their unborn kid without telling
him and so he broke up with her and he
was like i'm just gonna blast my whole
face to make myself
unrecognizable because i feel so
betrayed so he got all those joker
tattoos at one time
got his whole face blasted the whole
video is actually on youtube if you look
up like joker gang
tattoo uh time lapse you can find it
but i i've been i've known joker gang
for a while
maybe like six or seven months so i went
back and met up with him because he was
like you gotta meet my cousin he's a six
nine impersonator
that's how this video came to be and how
did you know about the first guy
no the guy who was eating his roaches oh
so he actually he reached out to me via
dm because he knew that i was
uh like doing a podcast at the sausage
castle and he's like yo i live a half a
mile away
like do you want to come interview me
and i was like yeah [ __ ] you might as
well do this
i like low level uh prank influencers a
lot lit blunt bubba
i wanted to talk about this [ __ ] around
here
he doesn't waste [ __ ] around here he
busts out like 20 roaches and just
consumes them all in front of you
and i consumed one too and i had a thc
induced panic attack
estimated six hours later at the sausage
castle i started having
auditory i hadn't consumed thc in five
years and i just
swallowed this dude's like [ __ ]
probably like spice joint
right i started hallucinating and [ __ ]
and i was freaking out
like i was sweating profusely and my
friends were like pouring water on my
head it was a terrible night but it was
worth it for that video
that's amazing that just eating one of
those dudes roaches could get you so
high
and you ate like 20 of them yeah or
something 20
let's see how many he ate when we
watched it i think it was 21. but did
you talk to him was he okay after that
yeah man that dude lives and breathes
thc
let's see
[Applause]
oh
just light it light it up fire it up hit
it one time and then let go of it
[Applause]
you got down you gotta swallow that
[ __ ] man
i can't believe that one roach got you
so good
i was blasted bro i wouldn't be
surprised if he's like spraying weird
additives on his [ __ ]
like sketchy florida gas station thc
enhancer
yeah i wouldn't be surprised either that
got you that high
freaking out and then so so what happens
here
is florida man says that joker gang's
been hitting up his girl
is that true or is that just set up yeah
that came completely unprompted i i
could not believe that gum gang had a
problem with joker gang because
two days prior i was like this is camp
this is too good to be true there's beef
here
i'm actually i'm gonna set up a fight
for them in a month or two at like a
youth boxing gym
and run like a pay-per-view oh i would
pay to see that all day dude
yep gum game he just hit me up he just
texted me i realized he was like
when's the fight happening i was like
bro as soon as i can get back to the
orlando
area it's going down you got a man
you should have gum gang dress up as
batman
um so joke so joker gang
how do they feel about being referenced
as florida man do they take cross with
that or they kind of proudly yeah i'm a
florida man
they want to be viral so bad it could be
like you know like
and you could just say anything man they
don't care how they're labeled they just
want exposure a lot of people in
in florida are like that lord has a huge
like jackass
for like prank hillbilly culture it's
like
people in florida and like the redneck
side are like more aware of
world star hip-hop and stuff like that
than rednecks in like missouri
i mean so they they want to go viral
like there's so many like
that's so interesting and that's how you
end up with characters like these i
guess but here florida's got a crazy
like
5 000 to 25 000 follower range
giant creed of like hurt yourself
influencers you know what i'm saying
like hell like injure core like
your head on the table type people down
there barbed wire
crushing cans on the forehead vibes yeah
seriously
um here's joker gang uh
his dm my con said hey buddy stay the
[ __ ] off my girls dm
leave me the [ __ ] alone you know for the
longest time he's been trying to troll
me and get me to fight i'm like hey
let's fight whatever now he's on
probation so you're gonna make that
joker saying to you in the messages oh
he's gonna [ __ ] me up he's [ __ ] my
girlfriend
i swear to god it's an embryo
[ __ ] over there watch out man
i'mma whoop his ass
i think that corona should fake as [ __ ]
north korea the russians [ __ ]
sound a chemical in the sky and [ __ ] but
i think it's fake because i ain't
catching that [ __ ] yet and i
i barely wash my hands why not
because i'm a hood [ __ ]
if you're [ __ ] these hoes wrong [ __ ]
the [ __ ] i've been [ __ ] the whole
rosters on the little kid bro dogging
doggy
i got six kids bro i came out to a bag
like like a straight way in no way like
trevor [ __ ] my baby my mother for like
nine months
before i even found out what the [ __ ]
was going on straight away these nuts
all right so uh so we're doing this
man these characters are something but
so like
these guys seem kind of like
unpredictable do you fight
but you know you don't ever feel
endangered around these kinds of
characters
no interesting
i mean it sounds like you consider all
of these people
friends yeah those guys are my friends
interesting that's cool everyone's my
friend
um flat uh burning
yeah there was this one moment from
burning man that really stuck out to me
is i know you try to play it straight as
you possibly can in
in most situations but i know i know
what you're going to pull up
yeah the one lady who's having an orgasm
and you're just as close as i've ever
came to laughing in any video is what
you're about to show
yeah and you just couldn't hold it
together it's funny because she was
pretty straight
playing it pretty straight and then all
of a sudden she just busts out with the
what the uh meditative orgasm or
whatever is
really going on i'll play this no way i
could have known that she was gonna do
that
i mean it just came it hit me so hard i
was like oh my god this is happening
right now
real time reaction you're gonna see i
mean your reaction was so funny
i'm gonna play it breathing and
why is it that you don't want to laugh
you just you're trying to stay in
character you don't want to insult her
i don't like to laugh in people's faces
yeah it makes me feel bad
yeah exactly you're just trying to be
respectful
yes yes
yes yes
[Applause]
yes
[Laughter]
that's a pretty good sample that was
beautiful that was pretty good i mean
all things considered i think you
handled it pretty well
you certainly put your best effort in
yeah
she was serious do you think she was
kind of bummed on that video
oh how come i don't know i didn't think
she expected so many people to see it
she didn't get tricked or anything but i
just don't know well how do you know
that you speak to them after the video
comes out
they the video comes out weeks later and
they're like holy [ __ ] you know my
grandma's seen this there's like things
that you don't expect to reach
like if you're in all gas no breaks
video everyone you've ever known
is going to see it because it's just
going to find your extended friend group
yeah yeah
people pass it from here to there but
how is it that they're contacting you
you guys swap numbers
yeah you know hey this is me her name
was rasmus like hey this is me rasma
didn't realize your platform was so big
like i'm happy that it's out there but
i'm feeling kind of like weird about it
and i'm like yeah like
i feel you but you know what she's
really saying though right
yeah she wants you to remove the video
no not she just wanted me to talk it
through
you know a lot of people just need that
validation of like
were you trying to [ __ ] me over like i
don't know people just need to be talked
through being viral
i mean like what's gonna happen and i
was like look man like
people aren't gonna come out of that
video being like i hate that person
right or like no they're going to come
in that video just laughing
yeah and that's it it's simple you know
it's not the end of the world to be
on one of the videos now we're super
cool but yeah
that's interesting i would assume that
she was just coming to uh
kind of being like hey man can you cut
that [ __ ] out but i i feel you maybe
you're right maybe
maybe my my mind just goes to a
different place more cynical place
yeah i mean i think that it's hard to
communicate
how big the show is to someone yeah
especially when you're meeting them on
the fly and i'm always
in the scene so i'm not like i don't
have a crew or a body you're not i'm
like next to
that like hey just so you know we're all
right a million people it feels
it feels douchey but then people want
you to like they retrospectively want
you to have
let them know how big the show was but
what am i like oh by the way like
yeah the engagement is [ __ ] crazy you
gotta hop on this [ __ ] like i'm not
gonna do that to somebody
yeah your show has grown a lot in the
past year how do you how are you feeling
about that i mean
are all your dreams coming true right
now because like
[ __ ] you're a young man you got tim and
eric
begging you for a show hitting you in
the dms
saying andrew we need this right now
i mean how are you feeling you got to be
feeling pretty good about everything
yeah feeling good but i'm just
transitioning you know because it kind
of freaks me out and stuff like when i'm
walking around like
and people would just like like freak
out you know like oh my god oh my god
i'm like
because i you know but i always study
the effects
of like young social media fame on
mental health
i think i'm doing pretty good but it's
definitely weird and like
i don't think the human brain is like
optimized you know you know too
you're pretty famous man like you like
you probably walk around and you're like
holy [ __ ] like
someone's stoked like and i don't even
know them like it's just strange like
you
got it it's just happened to me over a
year so you get used to it
but overall it's a good thing i'm just
trying to figure out how to navigate
social life now
because definitely all eyes are on me if
i go out to a bar it's like all eyes on
me
like if i it's just weird you just got
to operate a little bit differently what
i've been doing
is like keeping like old school friends
like really close
you know what i mean like my two camera
guys like we just keep our
like social world a little bit smaller
and stuff like that but
i don't know i think i'm doing pretty
good mm-hmm yeah it took me a few it
took us a few years to get used to it
it's definitely really weird at first
but then you kind of
like you said you kind of your your
circle gets smaller and
you're a little more guarded i mean it's
fine it's it's kind of what you just
have to do
to to um to navigate the
your your social world more but i mean
like you said it's
it's a good thing it's nice it's a
really nice thing being
people that you've never met and coming
up and saying nice things to you
they're always super nice yeah but like
you said
it's transitioning it's yeah you're
something that you have to like
get used to and learn how to do and
it's just weird y'all do you all go to
bars and stuff like that
nah no we're we're we have a kid we're
old now
i'm 35. i mean i don't really leave that
i don't really i go to work and i go
home
you know what i mean so i don't even
find myself out in public much but
we were lived in new york for a year and
we got it a lot there
and um yeah there's definitely a
transition that takes place
i can imagine going to bars and meeting
girls and stuff
because i've been married to to ela
since before
we were famous brielle how long have you
all been married for
uh we've been married now for almost
eight
eight years yeah we've been together for
even longer that's [ __ ] awesome
i want to get married so bad man really
do you have a girlfriend
no but i want like a wife you know let's
start yeah
you do you're commit you're you're a man
who likes to commit yes
i have a wife like y'all like you know
do like funny [ __ ] together what if i
did that it'd be awesome
i'm sure you're gonna have plenty of
girls that are gonna be interested i
like being married
i really like it i mean i know for some
guys do you guys ever like beef about
stupid [ __ ] um
yeah yeah of course yeah but i feel like
we've always been
really good like well you know
our relationships may be
more complicated than that because we
work together we do everything together
we're like always together and so
sometimes that can cause maybe more
friction than other couples would have
but for the most part i don't think it
causes much
i mean for the most part we really get
along like
there's no we fight about food a lot
like she doesn't like pizza what the
[ __ ] is that
but it's like a stupid pizza it's insane
and she goes yeah thank you andrew
interview her ask her questions ask her
about people
i always eat his vegetables right you
know you don't like your vegetables
vegetables yes i do you don't ever eat
your cucumber
on your plate a vegetable that's like
some
i think okay i don't know okay what
about like a cauliflower crust with like
veggie veggie toppings would you go for
something like that yes
compromise yeah i should try that
i would eat that there you go there you
go
as far as your refrigerator goes does it
have a feature where you can just
put your hand on it and water comes out
or do you guys have to have
water come from a separate place that's
not the refrigerator
we have a tap we have water on top we
have ice coming out of the fridge yeah
we got ice out of the fridge and we got
water on top
what do you do for watering your rv you
just have like jugs of water
damn i have the environmentalists coming
after me with this one but uh
bottles yeah i mean dude gallons
oh but that's not bad what else can you
do i mean you could
get individual dollar waters like poland
spring that sounds way worse
environmentally
i agree with that but the thing is
sometimes gallons of water have that you
why does water taste so weird sometimes
i wish we had a scientist
over here you know water tastes like
hella gross and plasticky sometimes
yeah most definitely yeah what is
causing it
i think heat first of all when the heat
mix
heats up the plastic and the water i
think you can get a really
funky taste i think most of the heat and
then i think it really depends on the
quality of the plastic as well
like some some companies get a really
cheap thin plastic that just like melts
into the [ __ ] water
and then some companies make a more
hardy plastic that doesn't bleed so much
what's your favorite uh water company
my favorite water is gonna be the
tap water from santa cruz and new york
city
whoa that was a meta answer that was
amazing i mean when i think about good
water that's what comes true
i don't really have a brand of water
yeah when we lived in new york we were
like
we would just use it from the sink and
we're like this is so good compared to
l.a
where in new york did you guys live
manhattan upper west side
upper west side oh big baller [ __ ]
like something yeah i mean
our apartment was like 2 500 a month and
we had we didn't have a kitchen bro
really yeah i lived out in queens last
summer it was chill
nice i like queens nice spot i mean
our youtube setup was the whole
apartment like
the table and the camera and the lights
that took up the whole place basically
yeah what's like a funny like influencer
like a youtube
cringe lord event that i could attend is
there any giant gathering of like
youtube zoomers somewhere um
[Music]
yeah vidcon is good but i think vidcon
there's not that many
i the tick tock [ __ ] is pretty good like
the you know are you aware of hype house
oh my god dude i met some dude in
scottsdale it was like call me little
eyeballs go over the livestream
yeah you should go to the hype house
yeah can you give me a brief overview of
what the hype house is before i dive
into this
oh well i i only learned about it like
the last week so it's just
it's where a bunch of famous tick
tuckers all live together yeah
oh my gosh but they're they're young and
rich i think so you can only imagine
like what goes on there is it dancing
like
yeah what do they do well so they
recently gotten a lot of controversy for
having birthday parties where uh
nobody obviously was was observing
the pandemic etiquette they had a huge
party
and a lot of them were vlogging it you
know
so but but what do they do i mean i saw
a brief clip i mean the party was crazy
man they were like
just very sexual it seemed like lots of
drugs and very sexual lots of alcohol
i don't know grinding and like snorting
blow or something i saw lots of grinding
yeah
i didn't see any drug use but i'm sure
that there's lots of blow there
they probably wouldn't show it but the
kids do blow or
they like drink lean and like take zans
like i said i'm a little out of touch
but from what i can tell
in l.a is that it seems like almost
everybody does
cocaine yeah it kind of always surprised
me the people it always surprises us
oh that guy does cook it like everybody
it's crazy like i'll be at a party
and you think you know somebody and i'm
like oh this guy's doing lines
it's wild but so does joe rogan do it
we never met joe again although
why not i mean sounds like he does
and that probably does oh breaking news
joe joe gets more joe like harvested
like
reindeer [ __ ] bile and like
tree fermented yeah ferments it he gets
weird say reindeer bile is that
freestyle or is that something that he
does
no i think he does that you heard it
here i don't think that's free stuff
does that have a dmt in it or something
i think he harvested dmt from reindeer
bio
yeah um no
i don't know because a lot of people's
like
have a lot of this conception about what
la is
and i have to tell you i mean ellie's a
huge town
there's a tons of different kinds of
people and and places to be here
i don't know i i mean i've i've been
here as a married man and
and as a like in my late 20s we came out
here
yeah i'm pretty much almost 30 yeah so i
don't know i haven't participated much
in like the l.a party like lifestyle so
i don't know but to me i really
i find l.a to be really chill there's
lots of space
it's really nice i mean i i think it's
kind of bizarre how everybody
has this concept of la being just a
total [ __ ]
yeah it is really strange like it's like
people [ __ ] on it like it's the fakest
place ever it's like
what place is super real like what place
is there no social climbing and weird
manipulators
right they make it seem like it's the
shark tank it's like i don't know why
your hometown
i mean look you know it really just
comes down to what kind of person are
you i mean
you don't have any sense for for judging
characters you hang out with i don't
know i mean i don't know why people say
that like
when we lived in new york you i've heard
so many times like oh dude you're from
l.a
[ __ ] l.a or like oh you're moving to l.a
bro why would you want to go there
and someone who grew up in california i
never heard anybody speak
about that about any other state like oh
[ __ ] where you from
but new york everyone was like [ __ ] la
and i never heard that before
imagine if you reverse that like you're
in l.a and some new york full was like
pulled up with like a yankee hat and
like a bacon naked cheese you know and
you're right it's pretty
i do like the bacon egg and cheese
though bro that's my [ __ ] so good
yeah i missed those yeah what's
the la equivalent of bacon egg and
cheese like mexican food breakfast
burrito egg mcmuffin yeah yeah
breakfast burrito yeah the breakfast
there's just drive through mcdonald's
everywhere
breakfast burrito yeah but but i think
the convenience is what makes the bacon
egg cheese
pop right breakfast burrito's not that
convenient because you've got to
go somewhere to get it i got one right
around the corner from my place
and also it takes time to prepare you
know
i don't know i think it's it's two
minutes i'll never get back
while waiting for a burrito yeah i'm
like [ __ ] hurry up no but
it's hard to find a place man it's not
like that gotta get to glendale where
did you say the absolute offices
bourbon bourbon i gotta get
time is money you're going to get
hollywood so quick
yeah you're still away bro i'll keep the
rv and if she ever gets weird i'm gonna
just go out to the salton sea you know
like bombay beach
right around slab city and just oh yeah
calm down
lots of mexican food though so let me
let me how's the love life with living
with three dudes in a tiny rv how does
that happen
well i had a girl living with me who i
was dating for like six months
in the rv for a long time yeah so it was
fortunate
wow so forget about masturbating do you
guys have to tell like if you guys want
to have sex
is it like guys you're gonna have to
give us a minute yeah it's not awkward i
mean
they probably go get food or something
it's not weird i mean
it's only weird if someone tries to do
it with other people in the rv and like
cool about it's like we can all feel the
rv moving
but that's gotta happen right because
like if you're with your girlfriend i
mean sometimes
[ __ ] just happens in in the night time
but have you had sex while your friends
were in there i mean
it has to happen what kind of stuff
happens in the night time can you
describe what happens
well you're in bed together just
chilling
and then all of a sudden you just all of
a sudden your penis is in uh
your girlfriend's vagina and your homies
are like a foot away from you
i try to i mean i'm sure it's happened a
bit like i don't really
it's just some attitude some respect
[ __ ] like you know yeah
you you try it out once and you wake up
and your friends are like hey dude you
have fun last night because you can't be
up until [ __ ]
five in the morning and i was like wait
doing what i was just sleeping
yeah you know i sleep crazy i kick [ __ ]
in my sleep i'm
nuts it doesn't work but i mean the love
life is good
it was cool to live with the girlfriend
in the rv
but you know we just start arguing a lot
that's how it gets
what kind of stuff you guys argue about
just you know day-to-day [ __ ] like
you know you live in the rv like i'm
kind of in control of where we go
you know because i'm on the production
schedule so someone has to be like all
in
for whatever the team wants to do yeah
it would just be destination stuff like
she'd be like i want to go here and i'm
like we have to do this
it was just it was too like it put me in
too much of a control position because
i'm basically in like a walking like a
house on wheels it's also an editing
studio and also like a tour bus
it was just too much to manage me and
her so cool it's just like
there's too much oh
can you can you say something your audio
dropped am i back in this yeah you're
back you're back
yeah i can see i can see that that's a
lot to ask
from someone i'm surprised she was down
i mean that's wild that's
that's that's pretty wild oh yeah it was
really sick i think when i get to la
i'll start like dating again and stuff
well we have a show we do this thing
called the bachelor i don't know if
you're interested in
we have oh yeah were we involved with
that project yeah
maybe i'll be the bachelor that's kind
of what i was suggesting but
just to give you an idea of like the
success ian
um our uh ian's really
he's the blue hat can you see ian
yeah when i talk he can zoom yeah so so
ian actually found the love of his life
on through uh
through the bachelor she lived across
country and she moved to l.a and now
they're together
so we have success stories
i mean calling the the way we did it a
success is a big
stretch well i'm happy for you man yeah
thank you happy too then the result was
good
yeah yeah the show never picked up it
didn't go anywhere
you're not mentioning the massive
failure that we also had though the show
has failed
twice yeah the show fell twice
yeah it tends to be a disaster but
anyway
um i think you'll do fine i don't think
you need our help yeah you won't need
our help if you're gonna crush it
um what else is there really to say
andrew all gas no brakes just
keep it up thanks keep your foot on the
gas
and and off the brakes don't even think
about the brake yeah
you seem like a really a great
down-to-earth guy
a genuine dude and uh i can't wait to
see what's next for you i mean i'm so
excited to see this show
i think it's going to be fantastic are
you guys looking do you guys have a
network in mind
you know i can't even talk about it man
okay that's fair enough but yes
yeah it's got to be adult swim right i
mean it's got to be a cartoon network
not even sure what those things are
never heard of those
[Laughter]
well nathan for you was on comedy
central actually so i could see comedy
central being
a potential you don't you don't have to
respond nathan
for you by the way what a show am i
right
so good just ridiculous amazing
i remember i wonder if he watches my
show that would make me really excited
he's great i
definitely think he works he's going to
he works with those dudes
but i wonder if he's seen it yeah you
know probably yes
is my bet man you see nathan fielder's
uh social post he had that one recently
where
you remember how the police were like
thanks for all the
thanks for all the thank you cards yeah
and nathan's like man and all this thank
you
letters too it makes me feel so good
yeah that was really funny
[Laughter]
yeah you're going to be one of the
greats man put it down
really interesting i think so yeah i
think so
because you're the genuine article bro i
mean it takes a special kind of
character to just hit the road
and do what you do before any of the
support or production or anybody
so you're just the fact that you're the
you're genuinely doing what you do
and now people are recognizing what you
do and just putting a little muscle
behind it i think that's the
the recipe for success right there i'm
looking forward to
it you know just a kid
good luck is there is there a wish wish
like what's what's your like your
most desired can place you want to go do
it but maybe you don't have access
maybe that you'll you can get access now
with appso behind you
well i always told my uh high school
best friend evan that
if i ever got rich i would get us all
like jet skis but not just me and him
but
all of us everybody so ideally
maybe tim and eric could suggest a spot
where i can get jet skis for a good deal
and then we could kind of
move around the country as a like a
fleet and all gastro breaks could
instead be a jet ski show in which we
move
port to port instead of from town to
town oh my god that'd be a hell of a
ride man
what do you call all throttle no brake
what do you call that on the jet ski
throttle bottle no way
just jet ski the jet ski diaries whoa
whoa
like like shea guevara motorcycle
diaries i'm saying
i'd read that i'm just jetski i'm all in
dude actually
i know what i'm going to do this weekend
is go over to patreon and yeah wild [ __ ]
that i haven't seen before
hit me up i'll i'll tell you what to
look at you guys are awesome man this
was hell of fun
thank you we should be real friends when
i come out there yeah
i mean yes i'd love to stay in touch i
mean we're all here in l.a
if you need help like finding a spot or
whatever i mean we all
we're all we can i need help finding a
spot yeah
yeah okay i'll get right on that
actually for real though it's a really
good time to look for an apartment
because
i know it's probably you know the
misfortune of others but a lot of people
are getting evicted because of
covet that's such [ __ ] man there
should be a moratorium and
that with the word for it rent should
totally be frozen until people are
awesome i don't know what's going to
happen in la because
obviously the city is more progressive
than most places in the uh
they have extended it here okay it's not
going to expire but
but they're not forgiving rent so
eventually everybody's going to be dude
how are people going to do that they're
not forgiving
so it's going to be all charged back to
you for the whole quarantine period once
you come out
that's insane these landlords man these
landlords are so predatory and these
real estate sharks man
the government's got to step in bro like
well there are
so so it is kind of some people
like there's such things as like co-ops
like where people invest
in in houses to rent so some people do
rely
their livelihood on collecting rent i
mean not not a lot of people are just
rich and
can afford to forgive the rent but some
people can't so
yeah i do wonder it's it's a tricky
situation but
i also just like how do you not pay rent
for five months and then you just have
to
owe that money i mean that's great yeah
yeah i guess i didn't consider the fact
that many of the landlords
themselves are like getting broke i'm
just from a gentrified city seattle so i
just assume that anyone who owns a
property is like a psychotic billionaire
no there's a lot of like just regular
people
that um that is their income you know
the rent that they collect so i think
for the most part you're right
you know especially like in new york
anyone who owns property there is a
psychotic billionaire
but i think in la for the most part
you're right but i know that there are
some people that rely on that income
it's kind of [ __ ] up situation for
everybody yeah
that ends that ends uh tomorrow right
then
or the end of the month the national
well i don't stuff is probably happening
while we're recording this so
whatever i'd say better check the news
well yeah because they're they're trying
to last minute
pass a bunch of stuff right now so
definitely check the news [ __ ] herman
cain is dead and i just hop into this
podcast in the dark about yeah
yeah yeah herman cain had one of the
greatest tim and eric ask
moments in like political history you
know what i'm talking about where are
you slowly
can you remind me about that here i'll
pull it up
um type on youtube um
herman herman kane slow smile
so he did oh here herman cain's creepy
smile in hd click that
so this guy did a political campaign
and at the very end did you see this
that i'm watching right now it's
unbelievable i remember this from so
long ago
this is real this was on tv bro
what intern approved this commercial so
he like slowly turns his head to the
camera
and then that's like some pervert [ __ ]
yeah oh my smile slowly creeps across
why is he breaking the smile in that way
yeah it's it's one of my favorite
and so that's that's what i that's how i
remember
herman cain rest in peace but if you
actually you know what's also kind of
wild about her mccain's uh
death is that if you go to twitter
herman cain's twitter
so herman cain's been in the hospital on
a ventilator for a long time
and his staffers whoever have been like
tweeting straight up
uh right wing propaganda and
anti-coronavirus [ __ ]
while he's been on a ventilator up until
hours before he died
absolutely that's some lunatic [ __ ] that
is insane they have been they've been
tweeting
and anti-coronavirus [ __ ] as herman cain
died on a [ __ ] ventilator bro
i don't understand how the world is the
way it is
i'm trying to find some of his uh that's
one of the craziest things i've
literally ever heard in my life
um like two hours before they announced
his death
on her mccain's twitter they said
they're tweeting about baseball
what are they saying about baseball he
said something has gone very wrong for
the situation to get this out of control
uh mlb investigating focusing on
massively
disruptive incident that led to dot dot
oh this is tweeted nine hours ago so
yeah literally as
herman cain was taking his last breath
yeah
and then two hours later they announced
that he died it's
[ __ ] crazy so anyway rest in peace to
herman though
uh uh let's see july 29th the day before
he he uh tweeted stammering babbling
inaccurate and barely coherent
it's classy classic nancy pelosi
as herman cain took his last breath in
the hospital
so there you have it politics to the
last day
let's go and let's go
that's about it eh well well i can't
wait to see in l.a
yeah yeah man when's this episode going
to drop
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow morning and
it's going to be the whole thing
the whole [ __ ] on youtube
including this part yeah no yeah no put
this part in for sure
it's all going in yeah yeah
super stoked man this is hella fun
well let's do it again i mean i'd love
to talk to you again once
once i don't know how long it takes i
guess it takes a while right to like
make a show and
fully until it like goes to air probably
takes a while
my ideal situation will be right around
the election
you think you can get it up that fast
man that'd be fantastic
we work every day are you going to be
doing like political stuff going to
rallies and [ __ ]
oh yeah that's oh that's that's just
watch i cannot wait definitely i also
want to meet i also want to meet a
passionate biden supporter
who's you know ideas go beyond like get
trump out of office you know what i mean
i'm just imagining someone like
right like trump level energy but just
biden right
yeah they're probably where would they
be if that person existed like
connecticut or something like that
no where is he from delaware i guess
yeah it would be
in dover delaware yeah there you go i
feel like he's one of those guys where
everyone in his hometown hates him
yeah you think he's like notorious you
know what i mean like
beat up corn pop but i'd love to i'd
love to see you because now you're with
app so you can get all kinds of
credentials to go to like uh convention
or conventions are we even doing that
man
[ __ ] no they're all canceled the the
major ones sucks
but it's kind of cool it's a blessing in
disguise because now we're the only
people holding it down
you're the only one in the game with
antibodies
you get tested for antibodies nah i just
got tested for the virus
i want you got to get tested for
antibodies i want to know if you've got
if you've
i have to have antibodies dude
you might be like a you might be like a
scientific phenomenon with the amount of
exposure you've had
oh yeah i'm the most exposed person
yeah you should get an antibody test i'd
love to know the results
i don't i don't like the nose the nose
pierced not the nose you know whatever
that thing is they put your nose no the
antibody they just prick your fingers oh
yeah no
oh i'll go right now i'm going right now
yeah well
we've said it all we've done it all
and uh can't wait to see what's down the
road for you so
andrew callahan yes from all gas
no brakes keeping his foot down pedal to
the metal
on patreon all gas snow breaks on
youtube instagram
facebook watch out for the portland
video man that's gonna be nice yeah
yeah when is that one can i expect that
i can't wait for that
in four days four days you're editing
you're doing an editing frenzy right now
as soon as i hang up to hang up the
phone
all right well now i know everything
yeah all right dude take care good luck
edit that quickly so we can watch it and
uh we wish you very well we'll talk to
you when you come when you uh get to l.a
yeah until then i love all you guys
i love you love you too i hope i can
count myself among your many friends now
my friend all right dude take care
bye see you guys